four years ago these best friends
discovered a hunt of time machine it's
the [__] 80s guys but what they did
in the past would change our world was
it morally wrong for me exploit my
knowledge of the future for personal
financial gain its call himself the
father of the Internet I'm the father of
the [__] Internet since I wrote let's
get it started back in 86 I've been on a
roll
Nick we're both a pop stars lately today
I recorded an original piece you say
only hear what I want to okay it was at
least a love song and I had to really
turn it all around yeah I don't feel
like anything Bad's gonna happen
he's been shuck dick you don't have to
touch it that hard my hand is acting as
a tourniquet what you work his dick
whatever he needs more time so we'll
give him more time Oh Lee [__] we gotta
stop the killer before he shoots Lou we
get blackout drunk we wake up back in
time don't mess with a win formula
huh the bonobos
boom Oh Lou I guess we were too late oh
my god sounds like hatred the only thing
he put his body was like Doritos and
poison like it Scandinavian gay bar how
far back do we gone to 1 to 24 we look
10 years into the future you look like a
miner Tyler Perry character we look like
Gandalf the poor I kind of like this he
look like Billy Zane's dick except not
as pretty that's fair
wait why are you alive I think what that
means it is killers from the future
we're here to stop your murder like
terminator you think everything is like
terminator cuz everything is like
terminator who in the future will want
to kill you I don't know everyone with
respect and kindness Lou America
what is that just like baby aspirin
except more of a super high intensity
psychotropic drug trip
the future is insane hey you booth
think that I'll hold you till later yeah
booth I think this may be my house now
it's a classic alternate reality
situation like fringe mmm you're a
[__] nerd nerd you're a [__] nerd
no one likes you play no one likes you
Hot Tub Time Machine 2 the hot tub
doesn't take you where you want to go it
takes you where you need to go Patriot
blue you guys gotta come with me why we
gotta make America happen bro no you're
not gonna be super welcome there but we
should totally go